the nebia by moan quattro is the world's
most advanced shower head it only uses
50 percent as much water but with a
super high pressure spray click the link
below and use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products
i want to start today with something
many of you have been writing to me
about and it's the question essentially
if joe biden doesn't run for re-election
do democrats have any good candidates
for 2024 particularly to run against
donald trump if he's the nominee or ron
desantis if he's the nominee now why are
we contextualizing this with trump and
desantis well because they're the only
two pool polling anything even remotely
viable in every cpac straw poll and
republican opinion poll it's trump
leading
and then ron desantis with between 10
and 22
depending on the poll or straw poll that
you look at everybody else is in the low
single digits so at least for now let's
theorize
that it will be or is likely to be
donald trump or ron desantis in 2024.
now i've already said before uh it's
unclear if joe biden is going to run for
re-election the language being used by
the white house is very narrow when
jensaki is asked questions like uh if
joe biden plans to run why hasn't he
announced or filed or whatever and
she'll say joe biden has the intention
of running for re-election which is a
very specifically worded phrase i think
they just don't know if joe biden's
going to run for re-election or they may
know he's not going to
and then the question becomes well well
so then what and much of this is wrapped
up with how the midterm elections go
much of this connects to
the continued and obvious efforts that
the right is going to make to take the
election whether they win it or not
and unfortunately it's not looking very
good
i think it would be an obvious lie if i
said to you there's a great bullpen
right now there's all sorts of great
people first of all if biden does run
for re-election against trump i don't
see that going well for biden and i've
explained before that one of the reasons
for that is
so far biden's presidency although there
is no doubt that there have been a
number of tangible successes which i i
outlined last week
maybe the week before
it has not been an interesting
presidency in the sense of inspiring
people uh joe biden's approval has been
trickling down and it seems to me that
uh donald trump if the if he was the
nominee against joe biden
would be able to sort of reinvigorate a
lot of the same people uh on whose vote
he won in 2016. i don't see that going
particularly well
um i i am unsure about biden versus
desantis but unfortunately desantis is
almost like a more competent trump which
can be very dangerous so then the
immediate conversation becomes if not
biden what about kamala harris it would
be natural in some sense
that there would sort of be a primary
but really that if it's not biden
the dnc would kind of anoint kamala
harris as the de facto nominee
that seems very problematic kamala
harris's current approval or
favorability is 39 percent
and that's lower
than every recent vice president and
some by a lot
uh at this point in time this was taken
at day 378.
mike pence was uh more popular and more
liked than kamala harris
joe biden was more popular and more
liked than kamala harris as vice
president
dick cheney was
significantly more favorable favorably
seen than kamala harris and al gore was
dramatically more favorably seen than
kamala harris so the numbers don't look
great for kamala harris right now it
looks like a very uphill battle if it's
going to be harris versus trump
or harris versus ronda santa so that
doesn't look good
then there was this idea of bring
hillary clinton back now i already
talked about why i think that's not a
good idea i think it can't possibly go
well
uh and
there are a number of different reasons
one is that hillary clinton never really
inspired
um
the the type of energy that i think is
necessary particularly running against a
reinvigorated trumpian electorate and
even if it's desantis it will still be a
trumpian electorate desantis is a sort
of trump although now they are publicly
feuding trump and desantis are the
electorate is quite similar
so then you've got the people saying
well bernie bernie's the guy it's
finally bernie's time
uh i'm not gonna blow smoke anywhere um
to me bernie's time is done
uh bernie ran twice uh he um would be 83
at the time of inauguration
if the idea is that there needs to be
more energy than biden although i agree
that bernie has more energy than biden
it's not seeming to me
like the guy who already lost twice
um is going to be the guy who at 83 is
going to come in and you know blow the
top off the electorate and defeat trump
or desantis if you have
evidence and data that suggests it could
be bernie let me know i'm willing to be
told i'm wrong but it's not seeming
great
then you've got the aoc crowd people say
aoc aoc has the energy she has the
likability that's true aoc has a lot of
energy aoc would be old enough to be
president
by two months
uh roughly two and a half months
something like that at the time of the
next inauguration
it's not seeming plausible to me
that 34 year old aoc
successfully runs on the basis that i'll
be old enough by two months on
inauguration day
that doesn't seem to me like the recipe
for a success i'm just being realistic
with you i read something about amy
klobuchar
tons of people hate amy klobuchar she
never pulled more than six in 2020 but i
have to tell you klobuchar to me sounds
less crazy than harris or hillary in the
context of 2024. now perry bacon jr
wrote a piece in the washington post
talking about can among other people
kentucky governor andy beshear
a white male democrat but from the south
and a governor rather than a senator
which sometimes can be more appealing to
people in
different parts of the country the south
the midwest etc it's an interesting idea
i don't know much about andy bashir so
i'll sort of put a pin in that but
that's something perry bacon jr wrote
about now perry bacon jr also writes
about tim kaine who ran alongside
hillary in 2016. it is difficult to
imagine a less exciting and more
milk-toast candidate than tim kaine i i
feel almost embarrassed to even mention
the idea of tim kaine as the nominee um
i it's it's very tough to imagine that's
the direction so i don't see any strong
candidates right now
a few things i will mention on rhetoric
and what i mean by that is
in terms of being able to mix it up with
people effectively in media and in
debates
um and come up with sort of like snappy
comebacks and and optics
there's something interesting about pete
but edge edge
but he's already suffered and been the
target of significant character
assassination in his role as a secretary
of department of transportation
secretary of transportation you don't
typically see that
secretary of transportation
into presidential candidate it's unclear
what his fate would be so i'm just not
sure about it and then it has to be said
that on policy
elizabeth warren is one of the most left
candidates of anybody who's recently run
other than bernie her wealth tax
proposal is something to the left of
what most democratic candidates have
proposed but
on a personality personality level the
country really does not seem to like
elizabeth warren so that doesn't seem
particularly good either so
it's a very tough situation
let's get through the midterms in so far
as what happens will inform what the
dynamics of 2024 might be
but i am not particularly optimistic
about the farm team right now
i'm open to having my mind changed let
me know what you think
this uh this is this is crazy to say
but courts around the country
courthouses
are bracing for violence
as a result of donald trump now being
under
three criminal investigations it almost
sounds surreal what it's
courts are bracing for violence because
trump is being how could how could that
be well yes it is 2022 and that's the
reality that we live in um i have an
article from a business insider trump is
facing criminal investigations into his
conduct courts are bracing for violence
and chaos
donald trump encouraged supporters to
protest where he and his company are
under investigation fulton county
district attorney fannie willis and
other officials aren't taking his
comments lightly officials in new york
atlanta and washington dc are
investigating whether trump broke the
law
um
the uh these cities are taking uh trump
at his word and preparing for the worst
in atlanta
uh fannie willis requested that the fbi
assess the security of fulton county
courthouse and other government
buildings i'm asking that you
immediately conduct a risk assessment
and you provide protective resources
one big reason for concern around trump
is simply his presence in a courthouse a
case or cases of this magnitude would
likely draw big crowds this would mean
more work for law enforcement and secret
service
um
we have uh the video of course of trump
at his recent rally actually saying we
there should be major protests depending
on what happens with these
investigations
if these radical vicious racist
prosecutors do anything wrong or illegal
i hope we are going to have in this
country the biggest protest we have ever
had in washington d.c
in new york in atlanta and elsewhere
because our country and our elections
are corrupt now understand that the code
of what he's saying when he says if they
do anything illegal and corrupt to me in
those places but what he's really saying
is
if they do anything
i will tell you that it is illegal and
corrupt
if there are any charges
brought forward out of new york
out of atlanta out of washington dc at
the federal level what he's going to say
that it is corruption and that it is
illegal
and he is already ginning up exactly the
type of violence that we saw on january
6 though on the one hand when we say
courts bracing for violence what quartz
brace yeah it makes perfect sense
of someone facing criminal charges and
the court system has to physically brace
for violence well yeah look at what
happened on january 6. in fact we almost
need to fortify the court buildings
because we can't count
on
it all being dealt with appropriately
outside those buildings because of what
we saw on january 6th i mean hopefully
it would be different hopefully in in
atlanta or in new york it would be
handled differently and knowing what
happened on january 6th they would be
prepared but it's a real and crazy thing
that this is being discussed the far
right is sort of being
worked up into a lather of seething
anger
at
someone for all of the things and
injustices that they perceive to have
been carried out against them
and
there are certainly injustices that have
been carried out against the average
person when we talk about the two
justice systems we have when we talk
about our economic system allowing and
even causing such inequality and
disenfranchisement of course
but
their ire is being pointed at the wrong
place at election systems that are
supposedly fraudulent at investigative
systems that are supposedly targeting
trump with the so-called witch hunts
they are being told something's going to
have to be done
but it always ends up being a cynical
use of these people by trump either for
their money or as we saw on january 6th
for their it's almost like for their
freedom they traded their freedom for
trump when he said let's go to the
capitol and more than 700 of them now
facing
criminal charges so this is a keg
that could very well explode now i think
it's important to mention one additional
thing
i
fear
a rise in violence
regardless of what happens to trump and
what i mean by that is trump in and of
himself is not the root cause
of
the weaponized xenophobia and
disinformation
and authoritarian leaning he identified
it as a good way to wrap up this
electorate that was to some degree made
up of people that were not really even
following politics up until trump
swooped in and said hey here's how you
can get involved and help me rise to
power
i worry that those people
are
likely
plausibly going to become violent over
the next couple of years even without it
being trump directing them to go to
courthouses and cities where he is
potentially facing charges which again i
still don't think is the most likely
outcome i think that there's a
propensity here for violence regardless
and uh that's a really scary thing if
you disagree with me
let me know you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving showerhead starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just a hundred and
nineteen dollars but nebia is giving you
ten percent off when you go to
slash
nebia.com
and use the promo code pacman the link
is underneath this video
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our audience to fund what we
do including most recently sending
correspondents around the country to
interview people at different events
like we did in conroe texas at the trump
rally a couple of weeks ago you can sign
up at joinpakman.com one of the great
membership benefits is the bonus show
and as i am now telling people if alex
jones hates the bonus show this much it
must be pretty interesting
oh now i don't have my file i want meant
to play my file and now it's gone okay
anyway alex jones hates the bonus show
and so uh that should at least make you
sort of curious about it you can sign up
at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22 to get a discount off of
your membership okay the latest
development in the joe rogan spotify
controversy is that the ceo of the
trump-affiliated right-wing social media
platform rumble
has offered rogan
100
million dollars to leave spotify and to
bring his show
to rumble there's a very short and
straightforward uh reuters report about
this rogan gets 100 million dollar offer
from trump-affiliated site rumble rumble
inc a youtube style website popular
among us conservatives has offered joe
rogan 100 million dollars over four
years for all his shows
days after the podcaster apologized for
using racial slurs in his content rogan
is facing backlash for covet
misinformation on his program hosted on
spotify
neil young and joni mitchell pulled
their content from the platform the
incidents prompted spotify to add a
content advisory to any episode
featuring discussion of covet as
scientists and medical professionals
urged the platform to prevent rogan from
spreading falsehoods so this ceo
um wrote to rogan chris pavlovsky is the
ceo of rumble and wrote dear joe we
stand with you your guests and your
legion of fans and desire for real
conversation so we'd like to offer you
100 million reasons to make the world a
better place how about you bring all
your shows to rumble both old and new
with no
censorship for 100 million bucks over
four years this is our chance to save
the world and yes this is totally legit
so there's a couple different things
here i think that that are important to
talk about
um first and foremost
there's a reality that more than likely
joe rogan can't just do this because
he's under contract with spotify if
spotify pulled
his show
uh they'd probably still have to pay him
uh even if they released him from the
contract they might still have to give
him something if he had some other thing
you know
we don't know the exact details of the
contract so it's it's like an offer
rumble can make
that's very unlikely to become a real
thing because of how these contracts
tend to work and i say that without
actually having looked at joe rogan's
contract but my my concern here is as
follows and many of you know that number
one i've been on rogan's program twice
um and when i was on
no topic was off limits and
i said whatever i wanted to and rogan
seemed completely open to listening to
what i had to say and and in a serious
you know and genuine way
and
since then uh i have not held back at
criticizing joe rogan when he has
engaged in spreading covet
disinformation either through things he
says or things his guests say that
remain unchallenged we lampooned uh his
bizarre interview with jordan peterson
like i've i've not held back at all i
know that some of my
progressive um
some of some parts elements of my
progressive cohort
have held back
and i don't know why it might be
they don't want to maybe lose future
access to rogan like as i've said
he may have no idea about the things
i've been saying and he might have me
back on if i said hey i'm going to be
down in austin and i'd love to be on or
he might never speak to me again i have
no idea i've not exchanged any messages
with rogan for a while i just call it
like i see it and uh on on the recent
stuff
i do think
that the things that are being uncovered
that rogan said are absolutely horrible
and disgusting
and i also believe that his apology was
sincere to the extent that
i don't
believe that deep down
he is
trying to spread disinformation i think
he gets lulled into it through something
that we might call
kind of like audience capture and guest
capture
the circle that he's in and it's like
you know there's people who are going to
say this is too harsh a critique and
people who will say i'm being too easy
on rogan i think the reality is that
while rogan has shown himself to be
significantly open-minded for a long
time
uh rogan is in a circle that is very
culturally conservative and that
culturally conservative circle includes
um
race-based jokes that i find completely
gross
and it all it also includes
certain ideology when it comes to
government regulation and covid and the
like i mean the guy has said
he has seen
the wacky texas governor greg abbott
personally since he has moved to texas
abbot's completely out of his mind and
rogan from what i've heard acts like
greg abbott is a reasonable normal
person to be listening to listening to
so
there's both
the audience of rogan skews culturally
conservative
and in addition to that he's in these
culturally conservative circles
which makes it so that he has more
right-wing guests than left-wing guests
now there's a list that has been
spreading of rogan's right-wing guests
versus left-wing and the right-wing list
is much longer the right-wing list is
much longer at the same time there were
some notable people missing from the
left-wing guests that he has had on me
for example i wasn't on that list i've
been on twice so i think with all of
these
no one thing really tells us everything
about this story but the real concern i
have is he's already
in a sort of right wing echo chamber
because he has gone to texas and he's
hanging out with greg abbott and all
these other people uh because he is
getting the most positive feedback from
the right wing who says his racial
comments are perfectly fine his coveted
comments are perfectly fine and so the
concern is it's only gonna get worse
and i think it's unlikely
that um spotify is going to drop him at
this point in time and from a very
practical perspective one of the worst
things i can imagine
is the show just getting more right wing
that that seems like it would be a bad
thing so uh that's my general
perspective on this at this point in
time
uh the things that that rogan has said
are completely indefensible and he
doesn't seem to be defending them and
there's questions as to whether the
apology is sincere or not i mean of
course that question can sort of always
be asked uh but
at this point the the worst thing given
the size of his podcast is for it to
become more of a right-wing echo chamber
he should be held to what he said he
would do which is to have more people on
with views based on
the accepted science
on covid and and he should be held to
that period end of story hey this is a
really strange video yesterday radical
republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
visibly struggling to breathe on the
floor of the house
ranted about mask now you might be
saying david hold on are you saying mask
or masks i'm saying mask she was ranting
about mask i don't know why she was
saying mask singular
uh she was everything about this video
is very very strange and look at the
amount of disinformation she packs into
just a 90-second rant georgia seek
recognition
mr speaker
i'd like to address the house about how
children feel about masks
how children feel
how children
feel about mask
what
the gentle lady is seeing seeking
unanimous concern
for one minute without objection
gentlelady is recognized
thank you mr speaker i'd like to talk
about how children feel about mask
what now i know that a lot of the stuff
she does is her accent and people say
david you shouldn't really talk about
that like when she says mental as
opposed to mental that that's her accent
but does that include i want to talk
about how children feel about mask
that doesn't seem like an accent that
just seems bizarre you see while they're
watching television seeing super bowl
games where adults are filled
filling stadiums without masks and
why is she out of breath i mean just
none of it makes sense join themselves
while they see concerts happen they see
people go to work they see adults going
many places all over this country
without masks they are forced to wear
masks every single day at school
they they are forced to wear masks all
of them and it's wrong actually it's
child abuse now i know that sounds like
strong words but it really is because
children are not at risk of covet 19.
now that is a lie that is a lie the
truth about kids in kovid is
that when the pandemic started
it did seem kids were less likely to
contract it remember that was the big
thing and that if they did
they had mild illness but as the
pandemic has progressed
that has changed it's still true that
most kids will have only mild symptoms
but most people who get covet have mild
symptoms
we are seeing
more and more children's hospitals
across the country with surges in
pediatric coveted hospitalizations we
have seen some specific conditions
that are side effects of covid that seem
to almost only affect children so it's
very much this whole thing about kids
don't have to worry about covid is very
much untrue children are at the lowest
risk but do you know what's harmful to
children having their faces covered all
day long at school not being able to see
each other's faces not being able to see
their teachers faces not being able to
learn properly speech emotions and
having that connection seeing each
other's faces and learning from adults
seeing each other's faces this is sort
of like you didn't read the book and all
of a sudden the teacher calls on you to
tell us what was in yesterday's
20 pages that we were assigned like this
she seems very unprepared for this in
more ways than just the heavy breathing
now while democrats are going on with
the mask for thee and not for me kids
have had enough and they're going to be
future voters and they are sick and
tired of being forced to wear a mask it
needs to end masking children is child
abuse now of course masking children is
not child abuse but anybody who's been
paying attention knows that the masking
is ending first of all
the kids don't really seem to mind the
mask that much i think i mind the masks
more more than the kids to be perfectly
frank but um the masking is ending the
masking is ending we've heard from new
jersey that they're going to end the
masking in schools
california is moving in that direction
new york is talking about it we're
clearly moving rightly or wrongly into
the endemic
phase um of how we are accounting for
this virus and the masking is ending and
again why is she out of breath
why is she saying mask singular we may
never know you can see this clip if
you're just listening today we'll have
this clip up on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome back to the
program johann hari who is a writer and
journalist whose latest book is stolen
focus why you can't pay attention and
how to think deeply again johan always
great speaking with you hey david i was
saying to you before we went on air it's
really weird whenever i talk to you
because you're like a voice in my head
that i listen to so much that it always
feels slightly surreal when i'm then
interacting with that voice but it's
lovely to be with you always always good
to talk to you and this is a really
timely book um
we first should start with
what is the case to be made for this
lack of attention and lack of focus
because there are some who say this is a
very popular story to talk about but
there's really no evidence that there is
a focus or attention problem at this
point in time so first question is how
do we quantify that this really is a
problem i used to say exactly what those
people say that you know every
generation struggles with attention and
nothing unusual is happening now
and i started to write stolen focus
because
i noticed that something really weird
seems to be happening to my own
attention with each year that passed
things that required deep focus like
reading a book having deep conversations
watching a long movie things that are
very deep to my sense of self were
getting harder and harder they were
getting more and more like running up a
down escalator you know what i mean like
i could still do them but they were
getting harder
and i told myself well this is just
aging right but then
i was particularly worried about a lot
of the young people in my life a lot of
whom seem to be kind of whirring at the
speed of snapchat when nothing still or
serious could touch them and i decided
okay i'm going to look into the science
of this i'm going to use my training in
the social sciences at cambridge
university to investigate this to see
what's happening and even very early on
some of the facts about this were quite
startling the typical american office
worker now focuses on only one task for
only three minutes for every one child
who was identified with serious
attention problems when i was seven
there's now a hundred children who've
been identified with that problem so i
want to understand of course there's
many complicating factors going on there
i want to understand what could be
happening so i went on a really big
journey all over the world i researched
this for three years ain't the leading
experts on focus and attention from
moscow to miami to melbourne over 200 of
them and did a really deep dive into
their research and what i learned from
them is that there's scientific evidence
for 12 factors that can make your
attention better or can make it worse
and loads of the factors that can make
your attention worse have been
significantly rising in recent years
let's give a real no sherlock obvious
example we sleep 20 less than we did a
century ago
and sleep is essential for focus and
attention when you're sleeping your
brain is repairing it's cleaning itself
it's healing if you don't do that your
brain is literally clogged up and it's
harder to pay attention dr charles
seisler arguably the leading expert on
sleep in the world he's at harvard
medical school said to me even if
nothing else had changed even if the
only thing that had changed is that we
sleep so much less than we did in the
recent past that alone would be causing
a very serious attention crisis but
actually there's many factors beyond
that and what i learned is when you look
at these bigger factors what you realize
is
your attention didn't collapse
your attention's been stolen from you by
these very big and powerful forces and
once you understand that it opens up a
very different set of ways that together
we can begin to get our brains back one
of the ones that's often mentioned is
very generally
social media and i think that that's
just not really precise enough from the
research i've done and tell me if this
coincides with the research you did
really what's that issue in a lot of
these things and it's particularly
notable with social media is
rapidly changing focus from one topic to
another
uh rapid fire and that that creates the
expectation of that continuing and it
makes it it's sort of like you're you're
not exercising the muscle of thinking
and focusing on one thing for an
extended period of time is that the
underlying reason why the social media
piece is often mentioned
i think you've as you saw often do david
you you brilliantly honed in on a more
complex and nuanced thing you're
absolutely right we tend to think of it
as oh it's just social media did this to
us the
the answer is much more complicated and
you've gone to one aspect of the
complication so to
talk first about that one that you've
just raised which is really important
this started to become clear for me when
i went to mit to interview one of the
leading neuroscientists in the world a
man named professor earl miller and he
said to me look there's one thing you've
got to understand about the human brain
more than anything else
you can only consciously think about one
or two things at the same time
that's it this is a fundamental
limitation of the human brain it has not
changed in 40 000 years
it's not going to change on any time
scale any of us are going to see you can
only think about one or two things at a
time
but what's happened is we've fallen from
mass delusion the average american
teenager
now believes they can follow six or
seven forms of media at the same time so
what scientists do and there's an
enormous amount of research on this is
they get people into labs younger and
older people and they get them to think
they're doing more than one thing at a
time and what they discover is
invariably you're not doing more than
one thing at a time what you're doing is
you're juggling very rapidly between
tasks you're juggling from one thing to
another to another and it turns out when
you do that it always incurs a cost a
psychological cost called the technical
term for it is the switch cost effect
so when you try and do more than one
thing at a time you will do
all the things you're trying to do less
competently you'll make more mistakes
you'll remember less of what you do
you'll be less creative and i remember
when professor miller first explained
that to me obviously i then did a huge
amount of research into the literature
on this
thinking okay i sort of get that but
this must be a small effect
the evidence is quite shocking on this
i'll give you an example of one very
small study that's backed by a wider
body of evidence hewlett packard the
printer company got a scientist in to
study their workforce and this scientist
split some of their workers into two
groups and one group was told just get
on with your task whatever it is and you
won't be interrupted and the second
group was told get on with your task
whatever it is and you're going to have
to also answer a heavy load of email and
phone calls so basically the way most of
us live now
and at the end of it they gave an iq
test to both groups the group that had
not been interrupted
scored on average
10 iq points higher than the group that
had been interrupted give you a sense of
how big that is if you and me got stoned
together now david if we smoked a fat
spliff our iqs would go down in the
short term by five points right so being
chronically interrupted is twice as bad
at least in the short term as a debate
about the longer term for cannabis um
than being chronically distracted or to
give you another study there's one study
that found just receiving eight text
messages in an hour
reduces your brain power for the main
thing you're trying to focus on by 30
i would argue most of us are losing that
30 most of the time that's why professor
miller said to me at the moment we're
living in what he called a perfect storm
of cognitive degradation as a result of
all these interruptions to what degree
is this sort of like you know you stop
lifting weights for a while and you lose
the muscle but then you can pick it back
you know assuming your health is
suitable for it you pick the weights
back up and you get the muscle back to
what degree is all of this a question of
the right habits and practices that can
be regained and to what degree does it
not seem that way so the evidence on
this is pretty clear you can get a
little bit better at it but not much
right there's just a limit to what your
brain can do like professor miller said
this is just a fundamental limitation
some people are slightly better than
others if you really put effort in you
can get slightly better but the switch
cost effect is that you know as
professor miller puts it a textbook
level truism right oh no no no so i
don't mean the switch i mean developing
the focus again developing the focus
again yeah
sorry misunderstood yeah your answer is
more scary in that context well i'm
sorry they go more no more
oh there is a huge number of things we
can do to get our focus down okay um and
i think we've got to tackle this at two
levels right with all of the 12 causes
that are damaging our attention and
focus which includes some aspects of our
technology but go way beyond it from the
food we eat to the hours we work there's
a huge array of factors that are pouring
acid on our attention but
in terms of whether it gets better i
think this for all of these factors with
one exception there's two levels of
which we've got to respond so the first
is personal there are all i think of it
as sort of defense and offense right
there are all sorts of things we can do
to defend ourselves and our children
from these factors that are embedding
our attention and i go through dozens of
them if you think about switching
switching which is one of the causes um
give you an example you can't see this
because it's behind my laptop but in the
corner over there i have something
called a k-safe i promise you i'm not
getting commercial sponsorship for these
guys i keep plugging them a case safe is
a plastic safe you take off the lid you
put in your phone you put on the lid you
turn the dial and it will lock away your
phone between between five minutes and a
whole day yes i will not sit down and
watch a film with my partner unless we
both imprison our phones i won't have
dinner with my friends unless we all
imprison our phones so that's one
example of dozens that i give of a
personal intervention but i want to be
really honest with people and i think
your audience is unusually well fit
fitted to understand this point
these individual tweaks are hugely
important i am passionately in favor of
them they will really help
but they will only get you so far
because this is a systemic problem right
at the moment
it's like someone is pouring itching
powder over us all day
and then they're leaning forward and
going hey buddy you might want to learn
how to meditate then you wouldn't
scratch so much so which logical
responses screw you i'll learn to
meditate but we need to stop you
destroying my you know pouring this
itching powder right right right the way
professor joel nigg one of the leading
experts on children's attention problems
put it to me
is we're currently living he said we
need to ask if we're currently living in
what we call an attentional pathogenic
environment an environment in which
everyone's attention is being degraded
or pretty much everyone's and if that's
the case then the primary set of
solutions we have to pursue are
environmental we have to together as a
movement take on the forces that are
doing this to us yeah when i've spoken
to cal newport about this and you know
his his concept is that of deep work
and you know he talks about at the
individual level
maybe when you're actually doing work
that's not email based you don't have
your email open in another window that's
like a that's one thing but if your
employer expects that you're responding
to emails within 10 minutes then it's
not really something that at the
personal level is going to set you up
for success no you've put that
brilliantly and there is a collective
solution to this that i've seen in
practice this is why i'm profound
although kalanipor is a good writer
gives good advice i'm very uncomfortable
with a lot of this because
a lot of it like
my case safe right that i mentioned the
thing that imprisons my phone i use that
for four hours a day
and i'm conscious that when a lot of
people hear that they're gonna go well
screw you i can't do that right
how could i possibly do that that's not
a kind liberating piece of self-help
advice that's a taunt to people i can't
do it so there's a solution to this in
france in 2018 they had a big crisis of
what they called le burnout which i
don't think i need to translate and the
french government under pressure from
labour unions and they would never have
done it without pressure from organized
labor set up a government inquiry to
figure out what the hell's going on why
is everyone so burned out
one of the things they discovered is
that 35
of french workers felt they could never
stop checking their phones or checking
their email when they were awake because
their boss could message them at any
time of the day or night
and if they didn't answer they'd be in
trouble right so i can give them all the
lovely cal newport advice in the world
they can't do it right they just can't
do it so
the french government again a stress
labor union pressure was crucial
introduced a legal reform
it's called the right to disconnect
every french worker now has two rights
your work hours have to be defined in
your contract and you have the legal
right to never answer your phone or
check your email when you're when your
um work hours are over so it's paris
obviously before the plague to interview
people about this you know when i was
there rent a kill the pest control
company was fined 70 000 euros for
trying to get one of their workers to
check his email an hour after he left
work now you can see how and there are
dozens of these collective reforms we
need to fight for you can see how that's
a collective reform that sets people
free to make the individual reforms that
many of them want to make and there's
dozens of these collector reforms
whether it's dealing with the food
industry because the food we are eating
at the moment is profoundly damaging our
focus and attention or whether it's
dealing with the specific aspects of our
technology which is not all of our
technology and it's not inherent to our
technology that are damaging our
attention and so i argue in the book
that just like we needed and of course
still need a feminist movement for women
to reclaim their bodies and their lives
i argue we need an attention movement to
reclaim our minds and it requires a big
shift in focus because at the moment
what i did when i couldn't pay attention
is i blamed myself i was saying wrong
with me right why am i not strong enough
why isn't my willpower good enough but
when you realize this is happening this
is a systemic problem a structural
problem that requires systemic solutions
you realize what's the only thing that
solves systemic problems it's movements
we need an attention movement to reclaim
our minds and and i would argue it
requires a shift in consciousness
we are not medieval peasants
begging at the court of king zuckerberg
for a few little crumbs of attention
from his table we are the free citizens
of democracies and we own our own minds
and we can take them back if we want to
and i'm conscious that can sound a bit
fancy or grand eloquent i'll give you a
very concrete example of a precedent for
this in american history that has
improved the attention of every single
person listening to your podcast or
watching this
in i think you're a little bit younger
than me david but i can just remember it
used to be completely normal it was the
standard form that people used leaded
gasoline in their petrol uh in their
cars right uh a bit before my time it
was completely normal that people
painted their homes with leaded pain
right and it was discovered in the 1920s
that this profoundly damaged people's
brains and it particularly damaged
children's ability to focus and pay
attention but for years and years the
lead industry funded a kind of
pseudo-scientific denialist wing of
science that denied this but by the
1970s the evidence was completely
overwhelming the exposure to lead was
profoundly damaging children's brains
and the lead industry funded funded a
whole campaign saying well the problem
is people just don't housewives don't
dust their homes enough encouraging
people to dust enough turns out dusting
doesn't deal with lead exposure so what
happened a movement of ordinary moms it
was overwhelmingly moms
banded together and said
why are we tolerating this why are we
allowing a for-profit industry to damage
our children's brains this is this is
crazy we can't permit this and so they
banded together and it's important to
see what they didn't demand
they didn't say
let's ban all paint
they didn't say let's found all gasoline
they said let's ban the specific
component that is damaging people our
kids focus and attention they succeeded
as a result the center for disease
control says the average american child
is three to five iq points higher than
they would have been had lead not been
banned so that's an example of a
collective movement identified something
in the environment that was damaging our
attention ordinary citizens banded
together fought it and succeeded so what
i go through in the book are these 12
factors that are damaging our focus and
attention now we've got to follow the
example of those moms and get them out
of our environment um in the very
limited time we have left johann the two
to three and sometimes four hour podcast
format has grown quite a bit in the in
the last few years um how does that i
mean is that related to what you're
talking about in that i mean listen it's
a different type of focus to listen to a
three-hour podcast or are the specifics
of how people consuming it really where
the sort of detail where the devil is
and it doesn't really deal with this
attention thing
no i think it's an example in the same
way that you can see that whole foods is
a counter movement to the obesity crisis
right you have an obesity crisis because
our food supply system has completely
changed that's profoundly damaging our
focus and attention it's also causing
obesity in fact has caused obesity for
me at several points in my life um and
of course that means that you then get a
subsection of the population who are
privileged uh who can then go to whole
foods right and that's great now we're
lucky because long form podcasts are
free so you don't need as much privilege
so i think it's absolutely true when you
create an environment uh which is where
you know
the average office worker is switching
tasks every three minutes
that creates a tremendous hunger for
greater depth and the thing we've lost
with attention this attention crisis is
depth i would just say to anyone
watching and listening think about
anything you've ever achieved in your
life that you're proud of whether it's
starting a business running a campaign
group being a good parent learning to
play the guitar whatever it is that
thing that you're proud of required a
huge amount of focus and attention and
when focus and attention break down your
ability to solve your problems and
achieve your goals also breaks down and
that creates a tremendous hunger for
greater depth greater engagement and of
course long-form podcasts are a
beautiful example of deeper i mean i
seem to have been on every long-form
podcast in the world in the last week so
i was like losing my voice the the the
these deeper conversations are what
we're desperate for in the same way that
we're desperate for nutrition in our
diets we just don't know how to get it
so i think you're you're absolutely
right and i think that analogy with the
obesity crisis is really important
because
i think we are now with where we are we
are now with attention where we were
with obesity and say 1970 right you were
beginning to see the beginnings of a
disastrous trend and people responded by
blaming themselves just buying diet
books and it was a disaster it didn't
work because it wasn't happening because
individuals failed it was happening
because the whole system failed which is
why we've got to deal with the system
we've got to deal with the factors that
are destroying our ability to focus and
pay attention and i believe i learned
for stolen focus exactly how we can do
that i went to places that had done it
from new zealand to france we can
absolutely win this but we're gonna have
to fight for our attention
the book is stolen focus why you can't
pay attention and how to think deeply
again we've been speaking with the
book's author johann hari johann always
great having you on i really appreciate
it ah it's totally a pleasure david i
meant to say on my publishers tase me
that people could also get the audio
book if they want to from any audio site
i'm also meant to say you can get it
from good book stores but i always feel
like saying well you can also get it
from bookstores if you want to there's
no rule about this right but yeah thank
you such a joy to be with you david
thanks so much
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show one of the things we've talked
about on the show for a long time is
that there seems to be something
sort of constitutional that's lowercase
c i mean with the constitution of the of
the right the the way the right is
where uh sort of like satire parody and
to some degree comedy
um
are just sort of like not working on the
right and so an example of that would be
this there was this old show that was
supposed to challenge jon stewart's the
daily show years ago it was called the
half hour news hour
and
it it just wasn't funny and it failed
very very quickly
and we've seen a lot of these right-wing
comedians
um
just
fail to be comedians and the new like
least funny man in america now is this
guy named jim brewer now we've talked
about jim brewer before he's become
kind of like an anti-vaxx
laugh at fouchy
uh laugh at science type of right right
wing comedian and it's like what does
that even mean at this point in time
and he really seems to have kind of lost
his grip with reality there's a new
video
that was published by
the reawaken america american faith tour
this is he's been going around with this
like religious revival kind of tour and
we played a clip of that in the past and
he did a video for them where he's now
talking i guess this is
i don't even know what he's talking
about i guess this is supposed to be a
commentary on joe rogan
and foreign policy
although it's hard to tell what this is
but the right thinks that this is funny
whereas i see a guy who's lost his
connection to reality probably worthy of
a psych eval take a look at this did i
think they think this is funny maybe the
voices are supposed to be funny what
happened was people like hey
what you know
did you see
that and also i was like rusher wants to
go to war
and people like do they really want to
go to war yeah ah russia you know what
um no more mandates uh maybe some
mandates uh
put out you you know what like what is
the critique here is the critique that
there are things in the news like i i am
not i don't know what he's what is the
point here tokens are problems
they are losing
grip
the right loves this guy i'm going to
show you a video in a second where
they're in hysterics it's almost like is
do you normally watch paint dry to the
point where this is entertaining but
beware
because when you're in power that long
you're not going down without a vicious
foam at the mouth battle and i don't
know what that's gonna do i mean i see
it now if they're trying to do to joe
this is a
psychological war
it is an american war when the white
house says
we
need to
censor
a
human being that allows conversation
guess what everyone you just been taken
over and you're just sitting there
taking it and you can
buy all you want that oh
and then when it doesn't sell they send
their stars
what on earth is this guy talking about
i mean really like
i if the point of that is to defend
rogan
i don't know that that's very helpful to
rogan to be perfectly honest it just
seems like the rantings of of an
unhinged person just as a reminder this
was brewer's in-person performance
at this american faith reawaken america
tour talking about fouchy and and some
other things and if you're watching
you'll see that the the crowd is in
hysterics are these must be the most
sheltered people in the world to find
this funny you know what a cockatoo is
cockatoo
look at the crowd
[Laughter]
and that that's what everyone's become
right
little cockatoos staring at the screen
facts and figures facts and figures
dr felty
whoa i guess you're right masks must not
work based on this routine right now
disclaimer
i'm not saying masks don't work just to
be clear i don't want to end up getting
in trouble myself
trust the science trust the science
now as i've said before he did trust the
science when sadly his wife needed
cancer treatment and he said with no
hint of irony
we are trusting the science we're
finding the best specialists we're
finding the people who know about this
stuff that's who we're following we're
not following
hannity recommending zinc or you know
whatever so
he's also a complete and total hypocrite
but the right finds this funny and that
should scare us as much as anything else
we see going on right now
within that right-wing cultural movement
okay i don't want to spend a lot of time
on this next story it's just downright
bizarre
maggie haberman from the new york times
published a note that was sent to
mar-a-lago club members last week
mar-a-lago is donald trump's one of
donald trump's clubs and i guess it's
where donald trump currently lives down
in florida um trump sent a note out
saying that he was going to be djing
this weekend
and um this is a this is a former
president it's a very very strange thing
trump would be
trump is going to be djing i don't know
what else to say
uh this note was sent out on
wednesday
great music will be played during dinner
on friday and saturday evenings with
president trump playing the role of disc
jockey the music will be amazing it will
be lots of fun and we will go until the
late evening for those who will be
unable to be seated the bar will be open
for drinks we look forward to seeing
everyone again very soon president
donald trump like is is this sad in some
way obviously it's listen there's
nothing wrong with the president djing
in principle but is there something sad
about what trump is now relegated to we
saw that video of him entering the
mar-a-lago brunch room and asking for
applause and there was sort of like a
little bit of applause now he's djing at
mar-a-lago
it seems it reeks of desperation
to just
hold any attention from people that you
can
um and also i mean in the same way that
trump doesn't really have friends in the
way you and i probably think about what
it means to have friends
trump doesn't really
understand or follow popular culture so
it's also kind of hard to imagine
trump picking songs i mean just it's all
downright bizarre
but
it is
the last attempt
to remain relevant during this period
between
losing the 2020 election and getting
involved in 2022 and maybe running again
in 2024 but i guess one of the fringe
benefits of a membership to mar-a-lago
that trump is now the house dj
on friday and saturday nights good work
if you can get it i guess i would say
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
this may be the the most chaotic
voicemail we've ever received
this is a guy who i guess has been
calling he says i haven't gotten back to
him i'm not aware of ever having
received a call from this guy
but
he repeats just about every
recent covet lie i can remember
there's a kid crying in the background
what sounds like his female partner
is yelling things to to him to say this
this almost is performance art of some
kind of avant-garde nature let's listen
to it together david pac-man this is
billy harrison again i see you still
haven't uh or let me rephrase that i see
you still haven't
so there's the kid in the background
just chaos uh responded to my voicemails
either you're scared or
i'm not aware of any voicemails and i
obviously you know we i have a thousand
voicemails to listen to right now we
obviously can't respond just like i said
you spread
misinformation
and you don't know what to say back to
me like i said anything that you say i
can debunk you spread missing makes you
lie math do not work so we have
peer-reviewed
rct's
masks work
that's a lot vaccinations don't work
that's a lot
vaccinations do so is well
he sounds linguistically confused he's
saying vaccinations don't work that's a
lie
anyway vaccinations obviously work very
well
you're 97 times more likely to die of
covet if you're unvaccinated the
election was stolen that's true
the election was not stolen there's not
even evidence that a single state was
stolen donald trump
was the greatest president of all time
that's true no evidence of that for sure
everything that i could say i could back
up what about you
it's funny how people think asserting
something is backing it up
i know i gave you my number and
everything else
so for me and you to go live
on your channel on your little show
and debate
and i can prove you
prove to you that your you're you're
bull
and that's all you do is spread
misinformation
lies i i like the woman in the
background yelling lies and then he says
lies yes that's exactly it what a
chaotic situation huh
yeah you'll take everybody else's
voicemail stupid [ __ ] about you leaving
the country i don't give a [ __ ] whether
you leave or you stay or you the the
person in the background feeding him
lines is i mean you could if this was a
skit you could not script it any better
i mean
oh well you can make fun of it
like i said all this you talk about
trump said playing trump bingo why don't
you debunk that he's saying saying nope
that's a lie
this is what really happened that's what
we do you can't
you sit there and play trump bingo
what about biden and the democrats and
you can sit there and say that you're
not a democrat all you want to i mean
it's it's quite i've it's quite
literally the truth i've never been a
democrat you're a [ __ ] democrat oh
okay a liberal democrat
a communist socialist
democrat meanwhile the left is like
david you really should be a socialist
why aren't you a socialist
and if you
ask ask me why and ask me the policies
like you like to have
everybody else
get me live on your show and i'll make
you look stupid about the communists and
socialists
i would love it for someone to make me
look like a communist like the first
question would be
tell me one
communist policy that i support anyway
that guy sounds like he's got a lot
going on i won't deny that it might be
actually fun if he called in
um so hopefully he will he will call in
during live calls we're going to talk
about what is happening with the beijing
olympics on today's bonus show
very low viewership and also
uh the the quarantine hotels are being
called quarantine hell
it's crazy what is happening we will
also talk about alcohol returning to
flights
in the u.s and concerns among flight
attendants groups about it i would be
concerned we'll talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpacman.com we will speak to you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the nebia by moan
quattro is the world's most advanced
shower head it only uses 50
as much water but with a super high
pressure spray click the link below and
use the code pacman for 10
off all nebia products